[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale en quelques minutes voici les
titres de ce mardi 23 juin
c'est une mesure pour inciter la
population à se déplacer à vélo pendant
le déconfinement bénéficier d'une aide
de 50 euros pour faire réparer son deux
roues le dispositif lancé par le
gouvernement est valable jusqu'au 31
décembre
reportage dans une boutique yvelinoise
lui a choisi les rollers pour faire son
tour de france ligny montrent un thomas
d'eric s'est lancé dans cette traversée
la semaine dernière un nouveau défi pour
l'aventurier qui a déjà parcouru le
désert de sel en amérique du sud l'an
passé et puis c'est l'une des
manifestations phare de l'art
contemporain dans le département
sculptures en l'île revient pour une
23ème édition à andrésy l'événement se
déroulera du 2 juillet au 1er novembre
mais avant de débuter ce journal cette
tendance qui semble se confirmer dans
les yvelines l'épidémie de coronavirus
continue son recul au dernier chiffre
donné par la rs hier lundi 431 patients
étaient hospitalisés sur le territoire
soit 14 ans - en 24 heures
même si dans le même temps on a
enregistré huit nouvelles
hospitalisations dans le département
entre dimanche et lundi les réanimations
ont aussi légèrement baissé elles
s'établissent désormais à 23 les
yvelines où la copie de 19 a fait 5 114
victimes à l'hôpital
un décès supplémentaires en 24 heures et
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
2085 personnes ont été guéries d'une
forme grave du virus c'est une nouvelle
maison de santé qui voit le jour à
plaisir les locaux provisoires de la
ruche le nom donné à cet établissement
ont été tout récemment inauguré en
présence de la présidente de la région
ile de france est les détails avec ce
sujet de marylène iapichino et de
nicolas landry provisoirement situé dans
les locaux de l'hôpital de plaisir le
temps de la construction d'une maison de
santé tout neuf sur le terrain voisin la
ruche a ouvert ses portes en février et
accueille déjà quatre praticiens
paramédicaux est très important ici à
plaisir c'est d'avoir à dos et la maison
de santé à l'hôpital de plaisir c'est
donc de permettre à toutes les personnes
qui sont malades d'avoir un trait
d'union
l'hôpital et la ville à peine ouvert qu
la maison pluridisciplinaire de santé a
dû fermer pendant le confinement
les praticiens commence donc doucement à
prendre leurs marques et se montre
motivé par ce projet la difficulté en
libéral c'est d'être isolé et d'être
seul donc l'intérêt d'être dans une
équipe pluridisciplinaire ces deux
d'échanger avec des collègues de créer
des projets c4 paramédicaux se sont déjà
installés le plus difficile reste de
trouver les médecins généralistes qui
intégreront la maison de santé
définitive cette infirmière libérale
originaire de plaisir est de la ville à
convaincre de jeunes médecins de
s'installer dans la commune pour qu'on
en a un qui est sûr d'intégrer la maison
de santé définitive donc début 2023 nous
l'espérons est normalement c'est presque
fait mais nous en cherchons deux autres
donc je continue avec mes collègues à
séduire à parler de notre maison de
santé parmi les objectifs de la ruche
pouvoir proposer des créneaux d'urgence
sans rendez vous le bâtiment de 600
mètres carrés financé par le département
devraient être livrés d'ici 2023
la ville de plaisir en assurera la
gestion
[Musique]
à la page dédiée au second tour des
élections municipales c'est ce dimanche
et à quelques jours de ce scrutin à la
verrière nicolas dainville tête de liste
une nouvelle dynamique pour la verrière
et conseiller d'opposition a saisi le
procureur de la république de versailles
la raison il demande une vérification
sur la légalité de l'occupation d'un
logement municipal par nelly du tube
maire sortante est également candidate
dans la commune et des faits qui
remontent à 2015 explications avec
nicolas dont brice le courrier date du
20 juin 2020 une demande de saisine du
procureur de la république de versailles
formulée par nicolas dainville candidats
aux élections municipales de la verrière
ils souhaitent vérifier la légalité d'un
fait concernant la maire sortante nelly
duthu l'occupation d'un logement
municipal à partir du 10 juillet 2015
on a mobilisé des juristes qui est ont
estimé qu'il n'avait eu aucune
obligation légale de la mairie
d'accorder ce logement à madame du tulle
et donc madame du tu as eu un avantage
elle a bénéficié de cet appartement
municipal alors qu'ils n'avaient aucune
obligation légale à le faire dans tous
les porte à porte qu'on a fait il ya un
grand ras-le-bol face à ce que des
citoyens élus ou simples habitants
qualifie de copinage et c'est vrai que
c'est fait nous ont été rapportés cet
argument il est vrai mais c'est un
moment important pour clarifier les
choses mises en cause nelly du tu as
décidé de nous répondre
une déclaration écrite lue par
visioconférence j'ai eu un logement de
fonction en septembre 2007 auquel
j'avais droit de par mon statut
d'institutrice exerçant sur la ville
quand j'ai obtenu le statut de
professeur des écoles j'ai payé un loyer
pour ce même logement en toute légalité
une fois mr après la décision de
monsieur de la démission pardon de
monsieur ajaj je tenais habite à la
verrière je n'avais pas le droit aux
régions sociale
j'ai donc cherché un logement dans le
privé que j'occupe depuis août 2010 8
voilà les faits et bien
procureur de la république de versailles
avisera mais bien sûr monsieur d'un big
s'attaque à ma personne pour faire
oublier qu'il n'a pas de programme
global et cohérent dans l'intérêt de la
ville
la campagne se poursuit les électeurs de
la verrière sont appelés aux urnes ce
dimanche 28 juin
d'ici le 28 juin un focus sur les
candidats engagés à guyancourt ils sont
trois pour ce second tour dont le maire
sortant françois morton tête de liste de
guyancourt pour tous 2020 est décidons
ensemble à guyancourt au premier tour il
est arrivé est premier il a à 2 minutes
pour vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la liste puis encore pour tous 2020
c'est une équipe qui est diverse dansez
dansez parcours dans ses engagements
elle est renouvelée aussi aux deux tiers
est important de dire ce sont tous des
femmes et des hommes qui ont montré par
le passé leur engagement pour l'intérêt
général en général et pour l'aiguillon
courtois en particulier c'est une équipe
aussi qui se reconnaît dans des valeurs
fortes
les valeurs de gauche voilà car nous
sommes une liste de gauche et non pas
sans étiquette comme certains d'autres
le disent ce programme nous l'avons
voulu lisible cohérent et réalisable
il est articulé autour de valeurs telles
que la solidarité l'éducation et une
volonté de renforcer également nos
actions dans le domaine de la transition
écologique
alors pour illustrer ces valeurs nous
agirons pour que chacun puisse continuer
à vivre à guyancourt notamment au
travers des équilibres dans l'habitat
par exemple mais aussi dans les dents
les équilibres entre espaces verts et
espaces habités et également de sur des
points qui ont fait effectivement leurs
preuves telles que le maintien par
exemple de la scolarisation des enfants
de moins de 3 ans
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été sollicité mais pas d'essai
soeur également très de manière très
récurrent par l'éducation nationale pour
ouvrir les écoles habituellement la
première semaine du mois de juillet la
dernière du mois d'août pour des stages
de remise à niveau nous sommes toujours
refusé cette année je vais le faire
effectivement parce que je trouve que
c'est une année particulière et que
certains élèves en auront besoin
la deuxième décision je vais prendre
c'est une réelle programmation
culturelle ludique événementiel pour
l'été à lui en cours parce que là encore
une fois très probablement que certaines
personnes qui habituellement partent en
vacances ne vont pas partir et enfin
dans un délai peut-être plus un petit
peu plus lointain mais pas très lointain
nous allons mettre en place les groupes
actions projets dont qui sont des
groupes de travail qui mêle élus
services de la ville et habitants pour
effectivement un certain nombre de
projets est l'un de ces projets
pourraient être par exemple le bassin
lewig route du maïdo un autre maire
sortant en lice à voisins le bretonneux
où c'est également une triangulaire pour
le second tour alexandra rosetti en tête
après le premier tour mène à la
candidature alexandra rosetti 2020 elle
nous lui avons donné deux minutes aussi
pour vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un petit plus mais c'est un
véritable atout pour la ville c'est une
équipe qui est à partizan qui est
implanté dans tous les quartiers de
façon équitable et c'est une équipe
représentative des 10 6 mois et c'est
également une équipe où il y a des gens
qui sont très anciens vie si noir ou
alors que tout nouveau vie six mois mais
qui partagent en tout cas la même vision
de la même vision de la ville de
préservation de la qualité de vie et de
son art de vivre mais aussi de son futur
[Applaudissements]
le point phare ce sera le lancement de
l'écoquartier de la remise qui bon qui a
été présenté aux habitants en décembre
mais qui devra être exemplaire en terme
d'aménagement puisque la nature va y ait
vraiment et trouver une place forte
le sport sera parfaitement intégré il y
aura des commerces et puis bien sûr des
modes de déplacement doux et ce sera
vraiment un quartier exemplaire et tient
tout de suite a relancé les deux cycles
de fond qu'on a abordé avec saint
quentin en yvelines en particulier comme
à la rue de l'amirauté nord la
passerelle bosse il alors on a fait pas
mal de choses avec eux avec des ateliers
on a travaillé que les habitants donc
tout ça est pas à remettre en route
et puis je tiens également à mettre en
place rapidement une task force comme on
dit sur le sur le problème de la
circulation pour relancer le dialogue
pour avoir un calendrier d'action qui
soit réaliste et concret il ya également
le projet du cimetière bien sûr qui
quitte à relancer et on a maintenant
toutes les études nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire des choix avec les
habitants et puis bien sûr il faut
absolument c'est une évidence lié soit
tiré les leçons par bandes de la crise
répertorié mettre en place les actions
nécessaires c'est à cette crise
sanitaire en lien évident avec la crise
économique pour que la commune joue son
rôle d'amortisseur social
[Applaudissements]
enfin on termine de ce tour d'horizon
attrape ali rabais la tête de liste de
la gauche unie pour que tu rappes
respire classé en première position le
15 mars dernier présentation également
en deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis le seul candidat habitants après
trappistes et ma liste des 100 % entre
amis sts les 41 colistiers sont tous des
résidents des quartiers de la ville de
trappes
ils ont des engagements à trappes pour
les un président d'association douzaine
de présidents se sont engagés dans la
liste pour l'avenir de crap et pour les
autres ils sont bénévoles dans les
associations qui font du soutien
scolaire les associations humanitaires
de la ville nous avons des délégués de
parents d'élèves des trappistes qui sont
ancrés dans le réel qui agissent déjà
depuis des années pour transformer leur
ville et au quotidien et qui l' ont pris
la responsabilité de s'engager
politiquement pour présenter un
programme dont considérons que la ville
de trappes a été beaucoup trop bétonné
ces dernières années si la
transformation urbaine était nécessaire
dans les années 2000 elle a été beaucoup
trop loin notamment dans les nouveaux
quartiers et nous constatons qu y
compris dans les zones pavillonnaires
les quartiers sont grignotées par le
béton et des bâtiments remplacent les
petits pavillons il sera temps de cesser
la bétonisation c'est un des engagements
forts de m'attaquer et au sein d'un
programme nous avons mis une priorité
modernisme en hausse par la création
d'aires de jeux de proximité pour que
les familles puissent s'épanouir dans un
espace qui ne soit pas encerclé par le
bitume et le béton
d'autre part donc c'est une
caractéristique de l'intrigué
[Applaudissements]
la première chose que je ferai c'est de
réunir les directeurs d'école de trappes
pour renouer une relation de confiance
avec ses directeurs et directrices la
relation entre la municipalité et
l'école s'est dégradée ces dernières
années par manque de confiance
par manque de travail en commun et donc
la première chose que je ferai c'est de
réunir ses directrices et directeurs
notamment pour organiser avec eux le
passage à la semaine de quatre jours dès
la prochaine rentrée scolaire
cela supposera évidemment que nous
travaillons main dans la main pour
assurer la continuité éducative que l'on
doit à nos enfants
faire en sorte que de le passage aux 4
jours soit accompagné d'un projet
périscolaire ambitieux notamment pour le
mercredi matin est également compulsion
mettre en oeuvre des mois de septembre
lors d'études gratuites après l'école
qui permettra aux enfants de rentrer à
la maison en ayant fait leurs devoirs
accompagnés par des enseignants
volontaires salariées par la ville sur
sept ans de travail et par des
animateurs diplômés
sélectionné par la ligue et ce soir ne
manquez pas un nouveau numéro de nos
débats en vue du scrutin des municipales
ce mardi ce sont les candidats est de la
ville des clayes sous bois qui
discuteront et débattront de leurs idées
émission avoir sur tv 78 et à écouter
aussi sur radio sensations il veut une
fréquence 98 points 4
[Musique]
coup de pouce ce vélo c'est le nom de ce
dispositif dont je vous parlais dans les
titres il a été mise en place par le
gouvernement depuis le 11 mai afin
d'encourager les français à privilégier
le vélo pour leur déplacement à montigny
le bretonneux une jeune entreprise
spécialisée dans l'entretien la
réparation des vélos voit d'ailleurs son
activité exploser ces dernières semaines
au rayon ce petit atelier installé dans
le centre ville de montigny le
bretonneux a ouvert lé 2 juin dernier
une ouverture suite à la mise en place
par le gouvernement de la prime coup de
pouce vélo dans le cadre du
déconfinement led pouvant aller jusqu'à
50 euros permet une remise en état
complète du deux roues
aucune démarche pour le client c'est
l'état qui rémunère directement
l'entreprise s'est beaucoup de la remise
en état pour des personnes qui
souhaitent qui souhaite aller au boulot
en vélo qui souhaitent utiliser vélo
beaucoup plus souvent
donc c'est souvent des vélos qui
ressortent de la cave depuis des années
qu'on a qu'on a laissée dans un coin
parce que parce qu'on n'a aucun intérêt
à réparer un vélo parce qu'on ne veut
pas et donc la prime a permis justement
à des personnes qui ne faisaient pas de
vélo mais qui en avait un qui en
possédaient un de le réparer et donc et
donc j'espère d'enfer d'enfer après pour
aller à droite à gauche quoi vélo'v
propose un forfait à 55 euros qui
comprend l'entretien pour un changement
de pneus ou de pièces et en supplément
pas besoin de rendez-vous les usagers
viennent directement à l'atelier déposer
leurs vélos en moyenne 24 heures
suffisent pour un check-up plus on va
vite plus on va chercher sur le grand
plateau ici et sur le petit pignon
je n'arrivais plus à passer certaines
vitesses voilà donc donc c'était
l'occasion
je n'ai eu à débourser que 5 euros pour
ceux qui ont du mal oui c'est très bien
pour un pour inciter à faire à remettre
en état le vélo ou à faire plus de vélo
et en dix jours une soixantaine de
clients ont emmené leurs deux roues dans
cet atelier pour se refaire une santé
le dispositif gouvernemental est valable
jusqu'à fin 2020 à lui à chausser ses
rollers après avoir ré traverser le
désert de sel en amérique du sud thomas
d'eric s'est fixé un nouvel objectif
c'est une immense un de 21 ans doit
parcourir du nord au sud la france sur
ses rollers et les partis la semaine
dernière depuis lille avec une amie
michael et demi d'euros les interrogeait
une nouvelle aventure pour thomas d'erik
satie montant de 21 ans va tenter de
traverser la france en voleur et oui
vous avez bien entendu
ce sportif de l'extrême est parti la
semaine dernière depuis à lille pour
rejoindre le sud avec son ami justin
andres 22 ans originaire des vosges
bonjour à tous les deux alors comment
vous est venue cette idée bonjour locale
alors cette idée est devenu un peu
communément suite au peu vide s'est dit
que c'était le bon moment pour y aller
par notre pays en france et à l'euro
l'eur c'est une pratique on aime tous
les deux donc on s'est dit que ça
pouvait nous réunir pour un voyage
alors est ce que vous vous présenter les
grandes lignes vraiment de votre
aventure
comment ça va se passer alors on a
commencé donc depuis lille là on a
récupéré une aux voleurs et ensuite on a
quelques grandes étapes 20 30 vers dijon
ensuite vers valence et ensuite le but
c'est d'arriver au moins à marseille et
après ce sera que du plus on veut
vraiment arriver dans le sud est après
l'espagne et comment ça se passe et ce
sera des plus tôt des petites routes
c'est à puteaux des départementales ou
des pistes cyclables on évite m'accuse
route ne pas rouler mais majoritairement
neissen la piste cyclable c'est plus
c'est plus sécuritaire pour nous alors
est-ce que tout est définie thomas
d'eric ou est-ce que vous laisser un
petit peu de place au hasard on n'est
pas à remettre en question notre
itinéraire
on peut très bien changer de trajectoire
au fil du voyage c'est avant tout l'idée
l'idée c'est de profiter on n'a pas
vraiment d'objectif sportif on n'a pas
de kilométrage de prévues tous les jours
c'est vraiment plus souple et le plus
important pour nous c'est de faire des
rencontres
pendant le voyage est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter vos rollers est ce que ce
sont des rollers classique où ce sont
des rollers professionnels alors on a
des rollers oxelo aimef 900 c des
rollers classique disons assez de ce
sont des bons rouleurs mai entrée de
gamme accessible
c'est pas des rollers à 400 ou 500 euros
professionnels donc finalement cédé
rolls et des rollers contre n'importe
quel des quatre noms donc c'est vraiment
ce qu'on fait c'est vraiment accessible
à n'importe qui faire un sac à dos aussi
grâce à cox et vous parlez donc un petit
sac chacun sa paie 40 litres à 2 à 48
c'est très peu pour traverser un pays
s'est séparé en fait c'est s'asseoir là
aussi un défi logiciel mais ce n'est pas
trop compliqué juste en d'avoir un sac à
dos avec des rollers non ça va parce
qu'il est assez petit assez compact et
c'est plutôt ses voûtes agréable de la
voir sur le dos au final épatant
dérangeant les comment vous faites pour
dormir
on a la tente dans le sac avec les
duvets nous cache dans deux sacs 20
litres faire entrer la tente les duvets
à la trousse de toilette et le reste de
l'équipement plus des pièces de rechange
pour les rollers c'est vraiment un défi
fins et tetris dans le sac
c'est assez amusant mais on a tout sur
nous on est capable d'être en autonomie
donc voilà on peut poser la tente au
bord de la route il faut mais la
majorité du temps mais c'est de saône et
du coup chez les gens pour qui nous
accueillent dans leur jardin et on dort
chez des gens très accueillants avec
nous il donne à manger à boire
on fait aussi de belles robes justement
vous êtes partis il y a une semaine pour
l'instant tout va bien les habitants
ouvrent leurs portes
assez facilement l'histoire alors que
les soirs on a dormi dans des jardins
tous les soirs on a rencontré des gens
parfois ils nous ont invités à dîner
on l'a par exemple ce soir on passe une
deuxième nuit chez l'habitant
chez les ch'tis on se trouve
guise dans l'aisne et on va dîner avec
lui ce soir on fait toujours de belles
rencontres
on n'est pas à l'abri de avoir une
rencontre ils ont ni gâtés ce sera
vraiment ce sera pas grand chose par
rapport à toutes les bonnes choses qui
ne sont arrivés à côté est ce que ce
n'est pas trop dangereux de faire ce
périple en roller en sachant que vous
êtes sur la route quasiment tout le
temps si c'est le cas il ya deux jours
dans une une descente en fait j'ai fait
une mauvaise chute et mon genou a cogné
sur le béton donc j'ai dû faire un petit
détour aux urgences pour vérifier qu'ils
avaient rien cassé donc tout va bien je
peux continuer à imprimer sait si c'est
sûr qu'il ya des risques
il ya des risques tandis qu'on est sur
le bord de la route tout le temps et que
bah on peut tomber on peut faire mal
avec les automobilistes pour l'instant
ça se passe bien ça se passe bien mais
chaque route c'est un petit peu une
découverte disons à on a souvent peur de
tomber sur des automobilistes qui font
pas attention donc le danger il est là
c'est le plus grand danger de ce voyage
avec moi on a vraiment des fois des gens
nous frôlons n'a vraiment peur de d'une
mauvaise rencontre avec une voiture et a
même chuté sur une départementale ça
peut ne pas pardonner
donc ça c'est vraiment l'aspect
compliqué du voyage alors thomas d'eric
vous êtes un habitué des traversées
extrêmes on peut le dire vous avez par
exemple traverser le désert de sel en
bolivie à l'été dernier le salar d'uyuni
est ce que cette aventure en bolivie
vous sert aujourd'hui disons que c'est
des aventures qui m'ont vraiment donné
confiance en moi
et du coup voyager en france aujourd'hui
ça me paraît moins dangereux moins
compliqué moins stressant que si je
l'avais fait avant mais traversée dans
les déserts de sel mais chaque voyage
est différent et en fait on avait peur
qu'il a à chaque fois sont très
différentes par exemple quand justin
allait tomber ni j'avais une
problématique que j'avais pas dans le
désert c'est à dire je m'inquiétais pour
quelqu'un d'autre que moi et chaque
voyage est différent je peux c'est sûr
que ça m'aide aujourd'hui mais j'avais
parlons pas de bottes pas à gérer dans
le désert dernière question qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter de la chance
de la chance avec les voitures
merci à vous deux et à bientôt sur tv
soixante dix huit pour le débrief de
votre aventure
cette bonne nouvelle pour les amateurs
d'art contemporain sculptures en l'île
aura bien lieu la 23e édition se tient
du 2 juillet au 1er novembre à andrésy
60 oeuvres ils seront exposés certains
artistes sont d'ailleurs déjà sur place
pour le montage de leurs créations
reportage manon varaldo en pleine nature
sept artistes finalistes sa sculpture
dans le parc de l'hôtel de ville
d'andrésy originaire de côte d'ivoire ce
peintre sculpteur est en pleine
réalisation du fed' yenni l'oiseau
protecteur il fait partie des 13
artistes présents pour la 23e édition de
sculptures en l'île parce qu'elle
protège
la population ces symboles de ma de
maturité de fertilité et de fraternité
je l'avais prévu elle a représenté ici
mais elle a coïncidé avec un peu avec la
qualité qui se passe en ce moment avec
ces histoires de race ils sont des états
unis ici avec la faire à demain en
france tout ça pourquoi jugé bon de nous
représenter un peu évoqué peut-être
réunir et un peu tout le monde
cette oeuvre est réalisé avec le bois de
la scène car pour cet artiste il est
important de s'acclimater à l'endroit où
ils se trouvent et utilise seulement
davis un peu plus loin
cet artiste lui utilise du gaffeur pour
son oeuvre est l'araignée de la maison
du moussel l'oeuvre c'est une
anamorphose donc l'anamorphose c'est une
déformation optique et si vous voulez
lorsqu'on se retrouve confronté à une
anamorphose on se retrouve confronté à
un espace à des volumes à du relief
on a d'un côté un bâtiment qui est
remarquable par son architecture c'est
un bâtiment de style louis 15 édifié par
un architecte à la fin du 19e et puis de
l'autre côté on a une une oeuvre de la
nature une pure oeuvre de la nature la
toile d'araignée pour voir les soixante
oeuvres de l'exposition d'art
contemporain le circuit de visite sera
modifiée andrésy en raison de la crise
sanitaire les artistes vont exposer
leurs oeuvres sur le centre ville
d'andrésy comme chaque année simplement
il n'y aura pas les expositions dans
l'île elle-même
j'étais dans l'île elle même comme vous
le savez nous avons dû
limiter le nombre de visiteurs dans
l'île le nombre de visiteurs qui passent
en bateau et que donc pour cette année
la manifestation se fera uniquement sur
le centre-ville du parc de la maison du
moussel jusqu'à la place du mais la
manifestation a été décalée elle débute
le 2 juillet et sera prolongé jusqu'au
1er novembre l'exposition sculptures en
l'île a accueilli l'année dernière plus
de 50000 visiteurs
et puis autre bonne nouvelle avant de
vous laisser le musée d'archéologie
nationale rouvre ses portes à partir de
demain mercredi un important travail de
préparation ont été nécessaires sur
place pour accueillir les visiteurs
après trois mois de fermeture un
protocole sanitaire a été pensée masque
obligatoire dès 11 ans à limitation du
nombre de visiteurs signalétique au sol
un nouveau parcours allant de la
préhistoire jusqu'à la gaule celtique
sera accessible en visite libre tarif
réduit il est également proposé des
visites conférences et la visite des
toits exceptionnellement présenté par le
directeur c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]